last year here at comic-con we had an
unexpected guest drop in on us it did
not go well I'll be honest he was booed
off the stage now he has demanded to
come back and visit again this year he's
flown in directly from his top secret
lair in golf club and mar-a-lago please
welcome captain make America great again
[Music]
hello everyone thank you coat an end and
please please please
correction I am now no longer captain
make America great again
I am president captain
Wow Wow listen to those Woo's they're
going back sir
I got to be honest with you I don't
think those are Woo's oh sure they are
that's how these nerds cheer I have had
the greatest year of any superhero in
the history of superheroes ever hashtag
ever okay well you know who's happy you
know was having an even bigger year
Wonder Woman
excuse me I do not want to talk about
crooked
Wonder Woman coming all right she is a
low-energy
what are you talking about what do you
talk about she has a number one
superhero movie this year what do you
talk about please all right I had proof
there is widespread viewer Freud now
that sounds like one of your crazy
conspiracy theories I don't like her all
right she walks around with that lasso
of truth keep that thing away from me I
can see why you might have a problem
with that yeah and you know what else I
don't like
San Diego oh my god this time of the
year the entire town smells like Jabba
the Hutt died inside of a fish doctor
[Laughter]
[Music]
boom are you on that was a good one
no wait wait wait if you hate it so much
in Cydia why'd you come back
well my son wanted to check out Comic
Con for his 40th birthday
come on that captain mate American
Junior
[Music]
look at him now that is a high quality
person he looks tremendous Junior
Junior junior
Jr who hurt you in showing Comic Con
captain make America great again Jr you
enjoying it
oh yeah this morning I went to a private
panel in room 823 at the Downtown Westin
ok I'm sorry that's excuse me
a private panel in a hotel room yes it
was just me and Captain Russia vodka man
and Anna Kournikova I told you to stay
in the car you idiot Conan we've got to
go well thank you very much for stopping
in you guys really lifted we are leaving
San Diego
just like the Chargers hell Hydra
[Music]
you really want to punch that son don't
ya